land so for home home force cooperation
europe and land
only domain commerce de la technology
security
[Music]
[Music]
poor poverty
recapitulative scholar president
visited
a resource
supplementary and now allow me to pass
the floor to a christian who has news on
our
efforts to investigate to support the
investigations into war crimes committed
in ukraine christian
thank you donna
today the commission is proposing to
amend the euro just regulation
you may recall that there is a lot of
work underway to support the
investigations into the war crimes
committed
in ukraine and to strengthen euro trust
was one of these work strands
due to the ongoing war it is difficult
to store and preserve evidence securely
in ukraine
it is however crucial that evidence such
as videos and audio recordings is well
preserved
so that the atrocities committed in
ukraine do not go unpunished
since march eurochest has already been
supporting an eu joint investigation
team
looking into possible war crimes
committed in ukraine
while eurochest has practical experience
on international crimes the existing
rules did not envisage a situation of
this scale and crimes of this extent
and this is why it's required to update
eurotrust's legal base which we are
doing today
the proposed reinforcement will give the
agency the legal possibility to collect
preserve and share evidence on war
crimes with the relevant national and
international authorities including the
international criminal court
you will find more details in the press
release and the not daily news online
thank you
thank you very much christian i will now
like to invite balash on the podium
he has an announcement on our work on
medical evacuations of people fleeing
the war in ukraine
continues
[Music]
we have had groundbreaking news late on
friday or early saturday depending on
how you look at it european parliament
and the council found a political
agreement on the digital services act
the tsa
which is europe's new rulebook for the
online world this agreement is struck
just a few weeks after the one on the
digital markets act is in the quote
president frontal line historic put in
terms of speed and of substance unquote
the dsa will establish clear and uniform
rules for all platforms
that many of us use on a daily basis
which connect users with content
services or products
dsa will bring more transparency and
control for users as well as clearer
responsibilities and accountability for
very large online platforms the new
rules will protect users and ensure
their freedom of expression
and they are a great win for smaller
business businesses who will find it
easier to compete innovate and scale up
we have published a press release
already on friday night
and updated our effects page the links
to which we find in our daily news and
we're also working on an update to the q
a thank you
thank you very much johannes
now allow me to
inform you that
today we will not be in a position to
take foreign affairs related questions
because both peter and nabila are away
but of course
that only applies to questions that we
take on the podium here during the
midday briefing because the team is
available
to answer any foreign affairs related
questions uh via phone or email
afterwards they couldn't just be
present physically or connected uh
during the midday uh briefing so i
invite you to get in touch with them uh
via phone or email as soon as as you
need them
on the
[Music]
david
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
you have your hand up is your question
about this
yes well let's take nabil because i
don't see any other questions in the
room
although it's about a different subject
go ahead
um
hi you hear me well
i'm good go ahead okay go ahead uh okay
thank you so my question is on the dsa
um
there's a big issue and
mainly on like in on social media in
general it's about the spam bots
and fake accounts
uh
is this gonna be
addressed by the dsa
and in which way
also in the united states now there is a
big debate about twitter
because
i'm sure you know that elon musk
offered to buy twitter company
uh
how do you see
such uh
like
development or or what do you think
about the impact of twitter being owned
by one
major
investor what do you think about the
impact of that on
freedom of speech thank you
thank you johannes
thank you
many different things there so first of
all of course the commission never
comments on on business decisions
especially not that they are in the
making and haven't been made but what is
important is that the dsa and together
the the sister proposal if you want the
dma
these are rules that govern social on
social platforms social media platforms
um and then all other platforms in the
in the single market so they are
basically the same set of rules for all
uh platforms that will do business in
this market with 450 million users and
clients if you want and so that is very
important so um
it doesn't matter who owns uh how much
in which company that the company needs
to follow the rules now to come to your
question on bots i mean
on the one hand the dsa
is about illegal content so illegal
uh content but also for example illegal
non-compliant products on marketplaces
but it's also about harmful content so
their
big online platforms need to do um
a risk assessment regularly every year
and an analysis what are there is that
they are platform poses and here
let's say harmful content plays a role
and if this is amplified by bots for
example this information would be one of
the four categories
that are assessed there could fall
within
within this risk assessment now it's of
course really comes down to the question
what platform are we talking about
what
what is really the risk that this
platform assesses but uh so it's not you
know uh one size fits all it's really uh
let's see if if you want the generic
assessment that each platform needs to
do other categories then this
information is for example um harm to
minors
freedoms and of course illegal content
so uh
very difficult now to say specifically
what the bots as such are targeted as
not to provision against bots but it's
about the fact what is the risk the
systemic risk that the platform
identifies and that it needs to mitigate
thank you very much johannes are there
any additional questions for johannes
on the sa or on other digital matters
that recovers
i only see martha's hand up but i know
that she wants to ask about something
else because she
explained that in the chat so
annabelle it's also about something else
it's about the chemical strategy so yes
um
i guess that's all for johannes today
thank you so much and marta the floor is
yours
i'd like to ask ballas about the health
care system that he has just announced i
would like to know a little bit if he
can specify a what is the list of the 11
countries i think you have said that um
have a grid to
to have patients from ukraine and i'd
like to know if they are already here
being treated in european hospitals or
not thank you
thank you martha and balash joins me
promptly to provide you an answer
yes thank you for this question indeed
so i can specify to you the 11 countries
that i have just announced so these are
germany
ireland italy
norway
denmark sweden romania
luxembourg belgium spain and portugal
and i also confirmed that all the 200
patients that i've been referring to
have already been transported to one of
these 11 countries either from poland
slovakia moldova or from ukraine itself
okay thank you very much are there any
additional questions for balash on this
matter or another humanitarian mattress
that he covers
i do not see
i do not see any so thank you very much
balash
then we have a question from
annabelle
in the in our system
it will be um
about chemicals so annabelle go ahead
ask your question
i guess thank you i hope you can hear me
fine um
i have a regard a question regarding the
restrictions roadmap that has been
published by the commission today um
they're speaking about the principle of
rolling lists could you maybe explain
that a bit further what does that
actually mean like once chemicals are
banned are they been forever or can the
ban be lifted for some reasons and
maybe if you can say something about the
scope like how many chemicals are we
talking about in this restrictions
roadmap thank you
thank you very much annabel i will
invite johannes to provide an answer he
is replacing sonia today and i hope he
has all the elements thank you
guys indeed replacing sonia today
yeah it's important to underline that
this is
let's say a planning huh that we put
that we put out there sufficient
document for orientation um so it's not
a new
way of banning at this stage but we're
happy to give you a bit more more and
more details so we published this
restrictions roadmap as you said it
provides detailed information on all
ongoing work on future restrictions
under the eu chemicals legislation
and the roadmap prioritizes group
restrictions for the most harmful
substances to human health and the
environment is set out in the chemical
strategy for sustainability
the restrictions roadmap aims to ensure
that the commitments under the strategy
can be fulfilled in a timely and
transparent manner maximizing efficiency
of use of available resources
in full respect of the prerogatives of
member states under the reach regulation
the restrictions roadmap includes a
rolling list of substances that you
highlighted in your question which will
become the basis for the multi-annual
planning on the reach the voting list
will be regularly reviewed and updated
and showing a balance between the needed
flexibility and commitment to ensure
progress
manny thanks johannes
are there any additional questions for
johannes on this
subject on the chemical strategy
uh yes roberts connected also online
hello
yeah
i just wanted to ask because this this
uh
restriction roadmap has come out i
understand
with the intention of preempting the
reform of the reach regulation
which is going to take a couple of years
to get into place
can i ask given your your focus on
on group restrictions of chemicals is
this something that you intend to
to codify an eu law when the when the
regulation is is reviewed
so is this is this going to become sort
of default practice in future rather
than the substance by substance
evaluation and restriction
thank you robert
johannes yeah
yeah thank you for your question now
this is really about planning and about
you know and showing um
uh pre um
previsibility in a way um but of course
this is not to be end any future
legislation or updates of legislation um
and you would in any case not comment on
anything that might be planned in terms
of legislative initiatives in the future
so i cannot comment on that
right thank you johannes
any additional questions for johannes on
the chemical strategy
or another mattress that he covers
no second time free thank you johannes
and yes please go ahead
hi tana
czech media um i have a question on a
letter that was sent to president for
the lion
by former prime minister of slovakia
robert
who's been enrolled in some criminal
charges back in slovakia and according
to various sources he has sent a letter
to
a few european representatives including
commissioner president fonder lying
saying that
the slovak democracy is at risk my
question is can you please confirm she
indeed got the letter and if you can say
whether she is she is intend to reply to
it thank you
thank you very much for the question
right now i am i don't have information
on whether she receives such a letter
but we will look into it and i will
provide you an answer i will i will i
will need to check
um so i will get back to you rapidly
after that
after the midday briefing
any other questions for us today
nothing from the room but i see that
leia has a the hand up so leah go ahead
hi thank you very much i don't know if i
should answer this question to you or to
peter who's not here it's about the eu
india ttc
um it's a very fresh proposal it was
only
a few hours ago so let's see if we
have information to provide you
satisfaction on the
questions that you have
okay thank you so yeah on the form and
content of the this ttc i wanted to know
if you already have
more information for instance if there
would be uh
working groups just uh
just like in the
eu us ttc second question is about the
timeline if there is already a timeline
for the launch of the ttc and finally i
also wanted to ask
how
this work in the ttc would articulate
with the negotiations on the other hand
of
a trade and investment agreement with
india because i know in the u.s case
it's clear that there should be no
negotiation for any kind of agreement
but in the case of india i don't know if
it's different or if there is a clear
boundary
thank you very much
very much for your questions leah um so
indeed uh this uh ttc trade and
technology council uh
uh will have its own dynamic um and it
always depends on the uh on the agenda
that we have with the partners so that's
why
uh you know this will follow its own
development and dynamic as the one with
the us follows its own dynamic as
regarding as regards the modalities
of work um
miriam can provide you
some
details
the ttc was launched politically this
morning
at the meeting between president van der
lion and prime minister modi as with the
technical work
let's see if we can have any additional
updates on how it would proceed
yes thank you leah so the mandatory
modalities of the eu india ttc needs to
be agreed between both sides so this is
still under discussion and will be
happening in the next weeks
and also the number and the focus of the
working groups as well as the candidates
of the meetings still need to be agreed
so at this stage we cannot provide
further details
as i said it's every every such
partnership has its own dynamic uh
depending on the issues on the bilateral
issues
that we want to work on and develop
together
and we'll provide you
details as those emerge
are there any additional questions on
this matter on the ttc with india
i don't see any so are there any
additional questions for miriam on
the matters that she covers
i don't see that either so thank you so
much
now any other questions on any other
matters
i don't see anything so thank you so
much for your attention uh do not forget
uh the resina uh speech uh which will be
the this afternoon at
approximately
2 20 central european
time
and
do not forget to get in touch for any
foreign affairs questions that you may
have today have a good day
you